good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight longtime Trump advisor Roger
stone was arrested on Friday by federal
agents and charged with seven felonies
none of the charges had anything to do
with Russian collision or election
meddling but she'd never know that from
the penalties he faces if convicted
stone could die in prison nobody in
Washington seems to find that punishment
excessive many have cheered it
officially stone was charged with lying
something most of our political elite
engage in every day but his real crime
was flamboyance Stone has spent the last
40 years giving the finger to the people
in charge in the end they got him they
always do
stones arrest is already fading from the
headlines replaced by the latest
political crisis of the moment or some
new skirmish in the ongoing culture wars
soon will forget it ever happened but
before we do it is worth taking just a
moment to consider a few basic questions
about it if only because nobody else is
going to first why did the Justice
Department stage what was in effect a
military assault on Roger stones house
stone himself asked that question on ABC
over the weekend watch the idea that a
29 member SWAT team in full tactical
gear with assault weapons would surround
my house that I would open the door
looking down the barrel of assault
weapons that I would be frog-marched out
front barefooted and handcuffed when
they simply contact debate you know it's
pretty standard for that to happen
that's pretty standard as you know but
is it pretty standard to send dozens of
federal agents with rifles to arrest an
unarmed 66 year old man who's been
charged with a non-violent crime well no
it is not standard it is shocking in any
honest person who pays attention could
tell you that Roger stone who was there
says there were 29 agents on the scene
along with 17 vehicles two of them
armoured and a helicopter overhead if
that's an accurate accounting it means
the feds sent
or armed men to roger stones house in
fort lauderdale than they did to Osama
bin Laden's compound in Pakistan just
for some perspective on this so what was
the justification for doing that
prosecutors knew perfectly well that
stone was not a flight risk he's broke
he doesn't even have a valid passport
they could simply have called his lawyer
and told him to surrender that's the
actual standard in cases like this but
they didn't do that instead they went in
with guns drawn
so who decided to do that and how much
did it cost taxpayers we spent the last
two days trying to answer those
questions and it tells you a lot about
contemporary America that we couldn't we
still have no idea the judge Department
wouldn't answer us the white house which
supposedly oversees that the Justice
Department didn't even respond maybe
they don't know the answer to those
questions possible they don't control
robert muller nobody controls robert
muller Muller can send our men to your
home to roust you from bed at gunpoint
just because he feels like it and
there's nothing you or anyone else can
do about it
Muller has an unlimited budget and no
timetable he doesn't have to answer
questions he can do whatever he wants
whenever he wants
to whomever he wants he cannot be fired
Muller is the single most powerful
person in America and yet nobody voted
for him hmm he is a living rebuke to the
principles of our democratic system at
the same time our leaders tell us that
we need Robert Muller an all-powerful
unelected prosecutor accountable to no
one to protect us from threats to brace
yourself here democracy
nobody in Washington catches the irony
in any of this Muller himself is a
threat to our democracy the most
powerful man elected by nobody Armenia
don't ask questions about any of this or
even acknowledge that it is a question
they've chosen sides here's Roger stone
from our show on Friday night it's
disconcerting that CNN was aware that I
would be arrested before my lawyers were
informed that's disturbing if it was a
dangerous situation which would merit
the SWAT team well then CNN's cameramen
would be and
I don't know why they would be allowed
to be there so that's a fair question no
matter who asks it and many began asking
it within minutes of Stone's arrest on
Friday morning how did CNN know about a
raid that was supposed to be secret did
they learn from Muller's team
well CNN reacted angrily to the question
were reporters they said we're not state
media we didn't collude with the feds
we used reporters intuition yesterday
CNN president Jeff Zucker dispatched his
minions to back down further questions
on this topic watch on the right on the
fringes of the right a conspiracy theory
spread and I won't get into it but it
was about CNN or Robert Muller and it's
spread that we were tipped off by
mullahs sure give me a break right to
embarrass Roger stone and to record his
arrest so I guess it would embarrass
them it's like they're saying as
propaganda a lot of people including
some mainstream commentators and
journalists started asking questions
about this conspiracy theory and I think
as journalists we have to be very
careful not to allow bad faith actors to
hijack the conversation and to move the
story away from what it really should be
safe that tape it's one for the ages
because it summarizes everything so just
to recap what you just heard we
journalists says CNN need to fight back
against the quote fringes of the right
who just want to quote move the story
away from what it should really be end
quote which it goes without saying CNN
decides they decide what the story
should really be and if you don't agree
you're on the fringes of the right in
other words shut up you guys stop asking
questions we don't feel like answering
but this show persisted because that's
our job and so we asked both CNN's
official spokesmen and the kid you saw
playing media reporter on the screen a
very simple question did Muller's office
help you with your story the response of
course feigned outrage how dare you your
right wing be quiet but when we kept
pressing them an interesting thing
happened they didn't deny it so to be
totally clear here's the specific
question that we asked quote did federal
law enforcement officials confirm the
raid on Roger stones house to CNN
before it happened very simple question
and when we pressed it CNN drop the fake
outrage they just refused to answer
because of course CNN talked to Muller's
people before the raid there was never
any doubt about that all the barking
aside Muller wanted the raid on Roger
Stone's home caught on tape and publicly
aired as a warning to other disobedient
witnesses about what can happen to you
if you step out of line
CNN was happy to oblige so CNN acted is
the public relations arm of the Muller
investigation as they have before and
then they lied about it in the most
self-righteous possible way and sent
those kids out on TV to lie some more so
it answers a lot of questions no wonder
CNN seemed so eager to defend Friday's
raid and to belittle and attack and
marginalize anyone who asked honest
questions about it the network is no
longer covering Robert Muller they're
working with Robert Muller and you
should know that as you watch it